The graph of the function g is shown below
What is the input value for which g of x
is equal to negative 2?
So what they do here is along the x axis
these are the inputs and then the graph
shows us what's the output
so when x is equal to 7,
G of 7 we see here is 1.
If x equals 9,
g of 9 here is 2.
If x equals 6,
g of 6 is equal to the y coordinate at
this point is equal to 0.
so what is the input value for which g is
equal to negative 2?
so this graph over here, this is y equals
g of x.
So g of x equaling to negative 2 means y
of x is equal to negative 2
And so when does y equal negative 2?
(muttering) when does equal negative 2?
(talking) it looks like that happens right
at this point.
And that happens when you input negative 9
into g.
g of negative 9 is negative 2
so this is going to be negative 9.
And we're done.